well in terms of being a control freak I
think we are all Confederates with our
our babies they have project whatever
they are so at what point do you know
that you can bring in an outside
perspective because you are maybe to
post something and you're overthinking
things yeah well we do it I mean worst
ourselves to do it yeah but we do it as
as early as possible so whenever we when
we get it when we get a draft of the
script so it's like you know traffic 20
or something and we've let a couple
really trusted people look at it and
give us some feedback but we feel really
comfortable yeah when we think like this
could be a good movie then we have a
public reading we just invite everyone
that we can think of friends families
foes like whatever you know whoever
going to give you yeah exactly people
who've never seen a stripper for people
who are very familiar with it and then
get some actors on them in the room and
do a reading and then give them very
targeted feedback forms asking specific
questions I mean you know the general
like how did you enjoy a great
characters from 150 block have a cute a
question answer just Russian live
discuss yeah just to see like oh my god
that makes no sense to anyone but us you
know so we start there and then you know
hopefully the people we work with would
agree but we try to be very
collaborative on every step of the
process so we're doing rehearsals of an
act you know we're not married to
anything like we just we just want the
movie to be as good as it can be so if
an actor comes with an idea that's
better than anything we could come up
with then move that's a good movie hang
the Edit process oh yeah exactly that's
why I mean working with another editor
on this as ours was so transformative to
the way that I work and think about
movies I tend to like when I direct
something and then I cut it I tend to be
very much a different person in posts so
that's why that's actually why I use a
suit of a pseudonym when I head it
because I feel like I'm a different
person so there are often times lynnie
will walk downstairs and I'm editing and
I'm cursing Chris the director as
Christie editor you know because it's
you know but bring bringing that extra
person in posts she came up with ideas
that I would never in a million years
been able to conjure up on my own but
something that I say because I say this
to my students all the time as well it's
like
our creativity has limits and the only
way that you're going to make something
better than what you can make by
yourself is with other people yeah so
yes like have a vision but be a
lightning rod for good ideas and let
people come in to the process and don't
don't be afraid of it look well and I
think with it I think it's only because
we took a leap and tried it and it
worked so yeah before a true yeah I mean
we got such great feedback and really
really found people that really want to
make help us make a better product and
sometimes that meant for instance in
this desires we had someone tell us you
should cut 12 minutes from the film yeah
and we were like oh no don't understand
what we do me know and then and then
after cute a couple days we're like crap
that that that note was one of those
things that he was like a little bomb
went off in our brains like at first
were like that's ridiculous those are
our favorite scenes we're not gonna lose
those and then the net the next time I
met with our editor we're watching that
that sequence comes on the screen and
well we all look at each other like
she was right but there is a point I do
want to talk about this because actually
joke and bellagio had written about this
when they were working with KJ and I
think it was Bellagio who wrote a blog
about it but there's this point where
every artist especially in a super
collaborative form that we are in film
there's a point where you need to take
it back and so while there while there's
there's those moments where we reach out
and say please give us your feedback and
we're going to work together we're going
to your ideas that's a there comes a
point at the end of that where you're
like okay enough it's mine again I will
make the final choice
and it's just knowing that and knowing
when to do that because it is it has to
be your vision and you have to you could
listen to people tell you give you
feedback forever job but there comes a
point when you have to just stand your
ground and say this is my vision and
this is the way it's going to be and
this is why but you went through that
process to solidify that and and and
when you when you when you have to you
know argue for lack of a better word
debate your why you do something or why
you're not doing something that just
solidifies what you know what what it
ends up being and there's that time
where you take it back and you say this
is mine again and I just bellagio wrote
it so perfectly that feeling as a
director to take that back yeah well
guess what is being an artist's if
nothing else it's just making the choice
to put the camera there or use this
color paint or you know put it back
we're not gonna agree with every choices
no so yeah yes but that's what that's
where hopefully that's our voice and
that's particular
yep
you